some more daily gaming news for you in
some very unexpected news that I don't
think I ever thought that I would be
reporting on uh CD project red who are
best known of course with the Witcher 3
and for cyberpunk 2077 tweeted this
today they said we're proud to offer
menstrual leave to employees team
members can now focus on their confident
help by taking time off when suffering
from period pain it's all about
inclusivity and fostering a supportive
workplace hashtag inside red they said
kudos to Gog who was of course part of
CD project for implementing this benefit
first and the internet uh largely does
not seem to be taking it well there are
definitely uh positive comments among
people I follow and certainly a lot of
women who are very appreciative but it
doesn't take much scrolling to get to
comments saying what about the men what
kind of menstrual leave do they have
right to and I understand what you're
trying to do but say you have a manager
choosing between two equally qualified
candidates one male one female the
manager knows one will work three to
four fewer days monthly if hired which
is more likely to be higher this leads
to fewer female hires